our friend Kyle kolinsky over at secular
talk recently did a piece about
reparations the United Nations saying
that they believe african-americans are
owed reparations in the United States
Kyle is getting clobbered by some people
for his commentary let's take a look at
some of what he had to say the United
Nations weighed in on the state of race
relations in the US and they had some
pretty harsh things to say so first and
foremost they said that the u.s. owes
black people reparations for slavery
now what led them to you know do having
this conversation or releasing the
statements that they released is of
course the slew of unarmed black people
who have been killed in the u.s. so they
came out and said you know what you
still owe reparations for slavery and
they also quote expressed concern over
the unresolved legacy of colonial
history enslavement racial subordination
and segregation racial terrorism and
racial inequality now I should be clear
though I mentioned that what they mean
by reparations is is pretty vague and
pretty unclear and in fact if anything
they allude to it not being what you
think it is they say it may include
quote elements of an apology and a form
of debt relief to the descendants of
enslaved people but on the one hand you
look at it and look it's fair to say I
never [ __ ] owned slaves no living
white person in the United States owned
slaves and no living black person in the
United States right now was a slave so
you know there's there one argument is
that's not like what what are you gonna
do like punish people who had nothing to
do with it and reward people who had
nothing to do with it and have no
first-hand experience that's one
argument but on the other hand the
argument would be
well look the US did 245 years 245 years
of slavery where black people were just
literally treated as property and they
were property in the eyes of the law
then they promised them compensation in
the form of 40 acres and a mule they
never gave him [ __ ] there were there was
also what a hundred years of segregation
and Jim Crow after that and then blacks
have only been free on paper all across
America for 50 years
right so 19 about 1965 is when we're
talking then to segregation and it's not
like by the way okay segregation is over
and now everybody all of a sudden views
everybody in an egalitarian way and
everybody's equal like I didn't happen
we wish that was the case on paper it
was the case like okay now everybody's
equal but look that wasn't the mentality
so you had 65 75 85 95 thousand five
thousand 15 yeah so about 50 years a
little over 50 years is how long on
paper so I mean if you really look at
the the scope of it slavery went on for
a really long time Jim Crow and
segregation went on for a really long
time and we're still like in the baby
phase of on paper even having free black
people all around America and then
obviously you bring up the aspect of
mass incarceration and you go well how
really free are not only people of color
in this country but also poor white
people in this country when it comes to
the drug war so black people minorities
are disproportionately targeted but
there are also a lot of poor white
people who are in jail as a result of
criminalizing substances and make no
mistake about it the history of it is
you do that to police the undesirables
so okay so we're gonna ban this
substance cuz it turns out Hispanics use
this substance is gonna ban that
something's concerns about blacks use
this substance so you know that the net
effect of that is that's why some people
call it the new Jim Crow is you know you
criminalize these poor communities and
it perpetuates this system of the rich
staying rich and then you know the poor
staying poor so now again people could
still look at that argument and they
okay but still today no white people
that are alive were slave owners no
black people were slaves so the whole
conversation is an unfair conversation
why are we even having it that's the
argument some people would make but
again the counter-argument to that is
the effects of that system which existed
for so long we are still feeling today
so a lot of people are reacting and
saying away away wait wait wait wait a
second wait a second
as Kyle is pointing out nobody alive
today in the US owned slaves
nobody alive today in the u.s. was owned
as a slave by American slave owners so
why are reparations necessary here other
people reacting a-5 eceived a few emails
from people saying wait wait a second
David if we are going to talk about
reparations for african-americans in the
u.s. today we need to go further back we
can find many other individuals who are
owed reparations for things that have
happened in the past I think that we
need to look at this from a couple of
different perspectives here okay there
are basically two arguments and Kyle did
a really good job of distilling these
number one is this does not apply to
people alive today thus there should be
no reparations the other argument and
this is an argument that really requires
thinking it through to figure out what
it is that we're saying is that there
are still repercussions to the fact that
we had years and years and years of
slavery in the United States one of my
favorite examples that explains this is
if you imagine the board game Monopoly
right you sit around with two other
friends and you start the game none of
the properties are owned everybody
starts with the same amount of money you
play for an hour many of the properties
have been purchased many of the cards
that you uncover and you get windfalls
whatever those have been acquired and a
fourth player enters the game that
fourth player is given the same amount
of money that everybody else started
with is allowed to take turns the same
way everybody else is allowed to take
turns and you could say listen on paper
everybody's playing by the same rule
right same amount of starting cash you
can buy properties if you land on them
if you land on properties that are owned
you've got to pay rent based on the
number of houses and hotels right the
rules are the same for every player but
clearly that fourth player is at a major
disadvantage by virtue of having started
later and that's really what Kyle is
getting at here when he says well yeah
nobody alive today was the either slave
owner or slave in the history of the
United States but we have measurable
differences in terms of how different
populations are living today as a result
of the fact that we had and you don't
even have to go back to slavery
interestingly you can go back only fifty
years to the 1964 Civil Rights Act prior
to which we had all sorts of established
discrimination against black American so
that I think is a perfectly legitimate
point of view for Kyle to take let's
take it a little bit further here what
about the idea of reparations or
settlements or money being paid out by
individuals who were not directly
involved in a transgression and being
received by individuals who were not
directly personally involved in that
transgression this is very common right
family members of people who died from
cigarette smoking regularly sue
cigarette companies and you may have
executives at the cigarette company at
the time who were not involved in the
cigarette production at the time that
this individual died and you've got
family members who were not the people
who did the smoking who are the ones
receiving the money from the settlement
that exists that's a common thing in
society so the idea that there's
something completely unprecedented and
unique about individuals who were not
the slaves receiving money there's
absolutely nothing odd about that now
you might disagree with it and then you
would have to justify why you are
against it in all cases but to say well
I'm against it only when it comes to the
long lasting impact of systemic and
established discrimination in the United
States that's a different story
the bottom line for me is I have no
problem at all
with the idea that reparations may be in
order here
it's a defensible opinion however it
applies to more than just black people
in the United States and I think the
problematic aspect would be
cherry-picking and saying of all the
populations around the world the only
ones who at this point deserve
reparations for something that happened
in the past are black people in the
United States to be clear the UN was not
saying at the exclusion of every other
group only black people require or
warrant or deserve reparations they were
saying we believe in this particular
case black people deserve reparations I
think if you look at the comments on
Kyle's video which we are linking to a
lot of the people slamming him have no
clue what on earth they're talking about